to present the next award a lady who won
an Oscar her first film cactus flower
and who was very exciting in shampoo
joins the gentlemen and director two of
the 46 pictures we started with tonight
West Side Story in The Sound of Music
ladies and gentlemen Miss Goldie Hawn
and mr. Robert wives
it's very special to me best achievement
in directing yes and I think we should
go directly to the note let's just do
that okay
the directors nominated our Roman
Polanski for Chinatown francois truffaut
for day for night Francis Ford Coppola
for Godfather Part 2 Bob Fosse for Lenny
and John Cassavetes for a woman under
the influence
the winner is Francis Ford
I almost won this a couple of years ago
for the first half of the same picture
that's not why we did how the Pope -
however it was Charlie blue horns idea
and when I heard it I said at first my
god to do a sequel to The Godfather is a
surefire way to fail and blow everything
I was lucky enough to get up to that
point and then I went home and I thought
about it and I realized that because it
maybe was such a easy way to fail which
was probably the best reason that try to
tackle what seems so impossible and it's
I'm really happy I did I just want to
thank Gordy Willis who was a
photographer who did a beautiful job and
Barry Malkin Valerie Malkin Richie marks
and Peter Zener who cut the picture
whoo-hoo-hoo all contributed Walter
Murch who did the sound thank you so
much thanks for giving my dad on Oscar
you